Question, how do you handle the objection
when you are pre-qualifying a business owner of,
I wanna know how much it costs or what's the deal?
I come across this objection in a call yesterday
and I was at the point that I wanted
to hang up the phone and move on.
The fact that I said we could talk about it later
didn't work, she was another level of persistence.
So, Juan, I know we talk about this in the training,
I don't know if you've gotten through
the entire training yet, but I push it off
as much as I can, mainly because I wanna take people
through the whole process and I've experienced this before
when I hired my setter, she started getting familiar
with the process, she started hearing me pitch
and they would start asking her, they were interested,
if people are asking those questions, by the way, Juan,
those are really interested people,
those people are asking buying questions
and that's somebody that's a good look, okay?
They're asking the deal because they're internalizing,
could this be a good fit?
So, what you need to do is, what I train in the program
as I say, I say something to the effect of like,
hey, look, that's not even, that's way ahead
of what we're even talking about here.
Honestly, at this point, I just wanna get you
a couple of free leads and we can talk about that
in a couple of days, that's the easy part, ma'am.
Ma'am, that is the easy part, I've done it
and I always say something like, I've done everything
short of taking food stamps for payment,
knowing damn well that I won't do anything
besides flat feet, but I don't wanna get them all nervous,
I don't wanna get them thinking, oh, you know,
if I just say, oh, we do a flat feet,
all they're gonna do is they're gonna start thinking,
well, I don't like flat feet because it's not guaranteed
and I like to do paper lead and I wanna do a commission
and by the time you get to the call,
they're gonna come in and they're already gonna object
and they're gonna say, no, I don't wanna do a flat feet, okay?
But if you can shit on paper lead and commission
in that screencast right before you get on the call,
you're not gonna have any objections.
So, I just like to keep it open and let them think
that, you know, there's tons of options
and I'm really just looking to find the right person
before we talk about that.
Now, if they're ultra persistent,
which by the way, I've dealt with that before
and it just gets to the point where it's like,
you're gonna lose, they'll say, yeah,
we've done a couple of different things.
Most often, what works the best is doing something
that's on a flat rate, that way, you know,
your marketing budget isn't gonna soar up in the spring
when we get tons of leads and one thing I don't do,
by the way, is commission and I'll tell them straight up,
I'm like, the only thing I don't do is commission
and that's because you got no skin in the game
and I'll tell them straight to their face
because I will not do commission
and there's no skin in the game, that makes sense
and if they can't understand that,
I don't wanna work with that person
because they're stupid.
Commission deal is the most stupidest thing
on planet earth with paper lead stuff.
They have no care in the world to close a deal.
So, hope that helps one.
I do know it's in the training, but yeah, a recap,
just something, some kind of one-liner of like,
that's honestly, man, that's the easy part
of this whole thing.
I've done everything short of taking food stamps.
Let me get you a couple of these leads
and then a couple of days we can talk about it
if it ends up being a good fit,
but let's not put the cart before the horse,
something like that, okay?
Make it smooth, make it not a big deal,
but if it's persistent, just say something like that
and tell them why right there,
but you don't need to like go into tons of detail.